und dann ist über ostern tatsächlich
noch eine art wunder passiert also
beinahe wie die spd im frühjahr 2018 mal
was das richtige gemacht hätte aber dann
hatte sie irgendwie doch kein bock mehr
ja ich war erstmal total begeistert sie
wahrscheinlich auch die spd will hartz 4
ersetzen durch irgendwas
menschenwürdiges hieß es ist doch klasse
denn die genossen haben sich das ganze
gehört sicher damals ausgedacht so aber
dann hat nach nach gefühlten drei
minuten diskussionen der olaf scholz
hier gesagt nee
grundsätzlich muss man hat hier gar
nichts ändern es schade wenn selbst die
fdp hat das thema inzwischen für sich
entdeckt hier riesenbeck ich kenne in
diesem land bürgerinnen und bürger mit
geringem einkommen
ich kenne bürgerinnen und bürger ich
kenne bürgerinnen und bürger aber leute
stehen habe ich nicht kommen sehen meine
damen und herren wahnsinn
sachen passieren aber zurück zur spd
zurück zur spd die einzige echte news
die von denen über ostern kamen war
jetzt unterm strich der berliner
bürgermeister möchte eine solidarisches
grundeinkommen für langzeitarbeitslose
klingt erst mal cool wer aber in der
praxis einen neuer niedriglohnsektor im
öffentlichen dienst dies früher abm
wurde 2012 abgeschafft weil es nämlich
quasi unmöglich ist jobs zu schaffen die
ja noch so gerade sinnvoll sind ohne
echte jobs in der freien wirtschaft zu
vernichten ja wir waren eigentlich nur 3
man könnte als lebender mobilfunkmast
funklöcher schließen
in der stuttgarter innenstadt den
feinstaub weg atmen und natürlich als
stützpfeiler für die kaputte rheinbrücke
bei leverkusen habe
liebe spd
[Applaus]
ihr habt ja ihr habt es ja gut gemeint
aber liebe spd meldet euch doch das
nächste mal bitte erst wenn ihr wirklich
eine idee hat wenn wir nichts hören ist
auch nicht schlimm denn natürlich
natürlich müsste man hartz4 reformieren
stichwort bürokratie irrsinn so ein
hartz4 bescheid hat auch mal bis zu 75
seiten jedes radiergummi für sein kind
muss man einzeln beantragen und die
jobcenter vermittelt am liebsten so
genannte massnahmen so bald ich maßnahme
vermittelt ist der erwerbslosen nicht
mehr arbeitslos
er gilt nicht in arbeit erfolgreich
vermittelt aber gilt erfolgreich
sozusagen vermittelt aus der
arbeitslosenstatistik
und darum geht's doch freunde ja nicht
rein in arbeit raus aus der statistik
das ist das ziel
und wer da nicht mitzieht krieg
sanktionen wird das extra rechnete
existenzminimum einfach mal gekürzt vom
amt oder gestrichen für ein paar monate
der bundesrechnungshof hat gerade
offiziell festgestellt durch diese
maßnahmen der jobcenter wird die
eingliederung der teilnehmer ich zitiere
nicht gefördert sondern oft sogar
gefährdet zitat ende
hier zum beispiel der beliebte kurs
arbeiten mit holz statt wie versprochen
etwas über holz herstellung zu lernen
landete sie mit anderen frauen in einem
kleinen raum die meisten hätten
strickzeug dabei gehabt um sich die zeit
zu vertreiben
vielleicht war das ja holzwolle nächste
woche kochen ohne herd ein total krankes
system der teamleiter im jobcenter
kriegt prämien wenn er genug leute in
solche schwachsinns maßnahmen ab schiebt
ihr noch eine schöne ein spaziergang
gegen die arbeitslosigkeit vergangenen
freitag in quedlinburg
und sie machen sie mit so einem
spaziergang die leute ist fit für den
ersten arbeitsmarkt haben wir ja auch
viele arbeitgeber auf der nähe sieht ja
was irgendwo auch in den fenstern
deutlich suchen
ja was denn so eine super idee wirklich
genau so bin ich übrigens auch an meinen
job hier gekommen ja wirklich ich war
wandern in köln kam zufällig durch
dieses studio habe den leeren stuhl
gesehen und zackigen dort meine damen
und herren
ab den er nicht der krieg war die
qualifiziert bin
einfach mal wandern was ich immer sage
wer arbeiten will